c'est vrai soit un bon jour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
le maroc a des relations de plus en plus
étroite avec les états unis comment
l'expliquer oui il ya des relations
traditionnelles le maroc depuis
plusieurs des depuis l'indépendance
était considéré comme manager ou un
partenaire important qui s'est renforcée
bien sûr depuis la lutte antiterroriste
dans la région et notamment
l'instabilité régionale avec le sahel et
le cas libyen bien sûr la crise les
biens le maroc rappelons le au les
etats-unis sont le premier fournisseur
d'armes du maroc à 60,62 poisson donc
d'armement un marocain achetés aux états
unis aujourd'hui le contexte est un peu
plus particulier parce que il s'inscrit
bien sûr dans le cadre de cette lutte
contre le terrorisme international dont
la légion notamment où ali la situation
au mali qui inquiète beaucoup d'opinions
publiés l'opinion internationale et les
états unis en particulier à milan si l
huile la reprise des pourparlers donc de
cette visite hier s'inscrit aussi bien
sûr qui conclut une tournée dont les
autres pays du maghreb la tunisie et
l'algérie et le maroc bien sûr donc
renforcer le rôle des pays du maghreb
dont dont le traitement au don le don
pour jouer un rôle meyer dont le
processus processus de paix en libye on
as parité libyen rappelons le le groupe
qui se dit pour parler entre les deux
protagonistes donc un taureau qui a
notablement d'autres broc et le chien
n'a après produits qui a commencé à
montre donc en suisse et ensuite au
maroc et qui a donné des signes quand
même positif
pour une paix durable en font moins
d'initiation pour la stabilité en libye
alors vous vous parle évidemment du
cadeau la lumière on sait que
pourparlers ont repris justement
aujourd'hui au maroc entre les forces du
général ali farzat et du gouvernement
national libyen de file s'allonge mais
au delà de la libye on sait que le maroc
plaide pour une normalisation des
relations avec israël
est-ce que c'est annie lieu alignement
sur la politique américaine peut poser
voilà quelques problèmes avec les pays
frontaliers du maroc le maroc eux se
trouve aujourd'hui dans une situation
délicate
certes avec bien sûr les relations ses
relations étroites avec les états unis
le font subir bien sûr la pression de
washington pour une normalisation avec
avec israël mais en même temps l'opinion
public marocain qui commence déjà à se
faire entendre contre toute
l'organisation contre cette
normalisation on connaît bien sûr la
position du peuple marocain donc
aujourd'hui le roi marocain se trouve
donc entre entre le marteau et l'enclume
dans le sud et satisfaire six alliés
donc notamment américains ou voilà ce qu
il va jusqu'au bout et affiche est donc
cette normalisation officialiser cette
normalisation ou bien et kita a créé
bien sûr qui a provoqué des tensions
internes or lorsqu'on connaît quand même
que la situation sociale économique
aggravée par par la crise du conte vide
qui touche plusieurs pays bien sûr non
seulement le manque donc aujourd'hui
risquent de provoquer d'autres arts
ou quelque sorte nous provoquer en
quelque sorte ces tensions v d'inventer
ces tensions et voir faire sortir les
marocains dont la rue justement le maroc
se trouve entre la tunisie d'un côté et
l'algérie de l'autre on sait que voilà
tous ces pays arabes ont été maghrébins
ont été traversés par le printemps arabe
avec des révolutions avec des révoltes
venant du peuple souvent contre les
gouvernements ou contre justement les
politique d'alignement par rapport aux
etats-unis est-ce que aujourd'hui voilà
les marocains eux
disons qu'ils ont plus de mal à
descendre dans la rue et à se faire
entendre
oui il ya plusieurs biens sur factor le
maroc justement sur cette normalisation
se trouve risque de se trouver si jamais
il est un est loin de se trouver isolées
notamment par rapport à en algérie le
mât et la tunisie qui ont rapidement
affiché leur opposition à toute
normalisation
rappelons le le président aisés dont ice
saïd qui a rappelé des cinq ans tente de
criminaliser toute normalisation de
leurs relations avec israël
donc aujourd hui le présidente e boon
également on a rappelé récemment donc
mais en même temps si la population
marocaine ne s'est pas révolté en 2011
celui des printemps arabes ou plus
récemment il ya plusieurs facteurs bien
sûr la politique sécuritaire au maroc
mais également mais également on regarde
toujours il ya toujours comme l'est le
comble un concept comme c'était le cas
on a craint aussi une population craint
toujours les dérives les dérives de
doigts qui peuvent que peuvent induire
les manifestations c'est ce qui freine
en quelque sorte les derricks vente ou d
au moins des manifestations bien sûr il
ya la répression intérêts
joue un rôle important également l'eau
maroc
encore une fois sur la question du
rapprochement avec israël ou la
normalisation avec israël
même si malgré une dépression risques je
crois de réfléchir deux fois avant de
prendre la décision
merci beaucoup brahim abou mansour
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur associé
à l'iris